-Our first guest tonight is
an Emmy-winning talk show host
and actress you know from movies
such as "A League of Their Own"
and "Sleepless in Seattle."
She stars in the new series
"American Gigolo."
New episodes air Friday nights
on Showtime.
Let's take a look.
-You said you talked to
that guy.
-Finnegan. Kevin Finnegan.
-Right.
-Yeah, I talked to him.
-Okay. What did he say?
-Well, it was hard to tell
what he was saying.
He was on his deathbed.
He was nearly gone, you know.
I get in there and I said,
"Who hired you?
Who hired you? Who hired you?
I'm talking about this case."
And I don't know what, but he
started, like, mumbling stuff.
Didn't make a lot of sense.
Didn't sound like words either.
But I thought maybe it would
make some sense to you.
-What did he say?
-He said Keene.
-Please welcome back to the show
and to her former studio,
the one, the only
Rosie O'Donnell, everybody.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
How are you?
-I'm well, how are you?
-I'm great. Do you feel it?
I know the physical space
is the same.
It looks so different.
-It looks very different.
But coming in here you get
the, like, "Whoa."
That was a quarter century ago,
right?
-It was a quarter --
Yeah, I guess 20-plus years.
And you did it I guess it was
about six, seven years
you did your show?
-Six years.
-Yeah. Doing it live.
You were doing it live as well.
That's a whole nother thing.
-And it kind of keeps you on
your toes though.
-Yeah.
-I didn't want some studio
executive to come and say,
"I didn't really enjoy
the Dom DeLuise cooking segment.
Could you do it again?"
-Right?
-And I was like, "Can't,
we're live. It's out there."
-I want to ask real quick
because I was lucky enough to be
onstage presenting this award to
Sheryl Lee Ralph last night.
-Fantastic.
-Which was really
a stunning moment.
First of all,
well-deserved award.
She's doing fantastic work
this year on television.
-Yes.
-It was scene stealing
on a night, where obviously, the
best in television are there.
-You know, I've known her
since she was in
the original cast of
"Dreamgirls."
And on "The Flintstones,"
she played the adoption agency
that got the me Bamm-Bamm.
-Uh-huh.
-So I've known her
for a long time.
And she's a genius.
She's an amazing artist,
an amazing woman.
And I was so proud of her, the
way she delivered her speech.
She sang from her heart.
I don't know. I was crying at
home, watching it.
-It was a really special thing
to be in the room for because
you realize in the way
that you've overlapped with her,
you got the sense she's been
doing this for so long,
in so many different places
that she had probably just
affected everybody's life
in there at some place,
and they were all so proud
and happy for her.
-Yeah, and to see someone
be able to really live
in the moment.
Like, I don't know,
when I've won an award,
I'm always sort of
out of my body.
And I kind of like watch it
going, "Oh, my God.
I got to say something.
Try to be funny,
get to the backstage area,
hold in your stomach."
I don't ever take the moment
to see somebody
just live authentically
and just land there and go,
"This is what I'm feeling."
-It was really cool to see.
-It was beautiful, I agree.
I loved the Emmys, by the way.
-I thought it was great.
-I thought they were great
last night.
-Yeah, I thought they were,
you know, wrong on one or two.
[ Laughter ]
I don't mean it.
-I love that, though.
I love the faces when you can
see the woman or the man
who doesn't win.
It's just a millisecond of,
"Oh, crap."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Well, that's when you go,
"You really didn't deserve
because right now you're being
a terrible actor."
-Exactly. Exactly.
-When they're like --
-Yeah. Isn't that nice?
I was very happy for Jean Smart.
-Yeah.
-That show "Hacks" is genius,
and she is astonishing.
-Very similar -- someone who has
been around forever
and just doing such great work.
And then all of a sudden,
a couple of, you know, projects
come that everybody's watching
and it felt like collectively
they all said, "Oh, Jean Smart
has been amazing forever"
and she finally gets
what she deserves.
-She's just been funny nonstop
through her whole career.
And she's doing dramatic roles
now.
And this role, I think, fits her
like a glove.
-Yeah.
-I just love the show.
I think it's absolutely epic.
-And it's a hard thing to do
when you play a comedian
because you have to be
believably funny in a way --
-Which she totally is.
-She really is.
-In the stand-up part, remember
Sally Field did the stand-up
show "Punchline"?
-Yes.
-It's a hard thing to learn.
But because she's maybe
naturally a comedian,
she killed it.
-Mm-hmm.
-She killed it
at the stand-up club.
Like, you're watching, going,
"This is so believable."
-I just read a wonderful
interview with you
in "The New Yorker" about
your early stand-up days,
that you decided to do that
as a path to find your way
onstage on Broadway.
-Yes.
-And so what was it about
stand-up that you thought might
be the first step there?
Because it does seem
a little unconventional.
-Well, there was a kid in my
class named Craig Minervini,
and his older brother Richie
was a stand-up comic.
And he was older by
like 15 years.
So came to see our senior show,
where you make fun of everyone.
And I was the star of it,
making fun of all the teachers.
And he said, "You should be
a stand-up comic."
And I said, "I really want to be
on Broadway
or a backup singer
for Bette Midler."
[ Laughter ]
The fact that I can't sing
didn't really stop me
from dreaming that.
-Bette Midler will take anybody.
She's not a perfectionist.
-She really will,
to be a Harlette.
That's what her backup singers
were called.
-I remember.
-That was my goal in life
and to get in a Broadway show.
So I said to him,
"Richie, I don't want to do it."
And he said, "Well, come down
tomorrow night."
It was a Saturday night
and all the kids
from my high school were there.
And I had no material
because I was 16.
And I'd say, "Oh, you know what?
Mary Lynn is dating Mitchell,
and Steve doesn't know."
And the class of seniors
were like,
"Oh, my God, that's so good!"
So I got like
a standing ovation,
and the owner of the club,
Richie, comes over to me
and says, "Rosie, why don't you
come back tomorrow?"
And I thought,
"Uh, it's a school night.
I don't know. It's a Sunday.
My friends won't -- Okay."
I went back and I killed.
I mean, I bombed.
I mean, I bombed a death
that could have been heard
in other countries far away.
It was pure silence.
And I walked off and he said,
"So that's pretty much the life
of a comic.
You kill it one night,
and you really suck the next.
And why don't you come back
and be the emcee?"
-Oh, wow.
-And that's how I learned to do
stand-up, by watching all those
comics for so many years
and being the one
to introduce them
and then sit in the club
and watch them.
-That's fascinating because I
bet you were both learning
how to be a comic by watching,
but I bet you were also learning
host skills by being an emcee.
-100%.
-Yeah. Because the host's job,
certainly those stand-up nights,
is to make the room better
for the people who are going
to come onstage.
-Exactly.
-And I would imagine
you were great at that.
-I really loved doing it
because I really loved
supporting the other acts.
I really loved getting the crowd
ready and not doing too much
to spoil them for the headliner
or whatnot.
And then Shirley Hemphill
was the headliner.
And she came in and saw me
on the open-mike night before.
And she said to the club owner,
Richie,
"You're going to pay her
$50 a show
and she's going to open for me
this weekend."
He said, "No way, we pay her 20
bucks to emcee the whole night
and we're not doing that."
And she said,
"Then I'm walking."
And she literally threatened
to walk out of the club.
And he had to fold.
And he hired me and I made $300
in a weekend, when you're 16.
I thought I was like
Leona Helmsley.
I'm like, "Everybody --"
or Oprah, "You have a car.
You have a car." You know?
-That's wonderful.
[ Applause ]
Obviously you're back
in your old studio.
You got to revisit another piece
of your old work.
There's a wonderful "League of
Their Own" television show
right now that you guys are
doing a cameo in.
-Yes.
-We've talked in the past
about the film itself,
which is really perfection.
-It really is.
-It's so tight.
And it's so well-crafted and the
performances are indelible.
Did you have any hesitation
when you heard,
"Oh, they're going to make
a series"?
-Well, I met Abbi Jacobson
with Natasha Lyonne.
I'm friends with Natasha.
We did a play together.
And she's introduced me to
these 30-year-old kids
who are unbelievably gifted.
And so she brings Abbi
to dinner, and Abbi says,
"I met with Penny" --
this is like 2018 --
"and she said she would be very
supportive of us doing a show
that 'League of Their Own'
is based on
but looks more into
the sexuality
and the private lives
and the racism that occurred."
And I remember thinking, "That's
going to be tough, right?"
But I didn't say that to her,
I said, "Well, all the support
you need, if you ever need me
to play like a butchy bartender,
just call me up, you know?"
[ Laughter ]
And so when the show was written
she called me up, she said,
"Remember that
butchy bartender?"
I said, "Yes, I do."
She said,
"Will you come to Pittsburgh?"
And I walked into the set
and here are all these
30-year-old women,
like I was when I did it,
wearing our uniforms,
saying like the lines
in the vernacular of the 1940s.
It was like I flashed back
all of a sudden.
And I realized
that was half my life ago.
-Yeah.
-Because I'm 60.
And I was 30
when I was doing that show.
And I just looked at them
and thought,
"What an amazing 30 years
you guys have left."
That was the start of my career.
And this is the start of
many of their careers.
And to look back at 60 and go,
"My God, what you have coming up
is going to be thrilling."
-It must also be thrilling for
you to notice in those 30 years,
you know, sexuality was --
you could maybe say was
some subtext
in the original film.
-Not really.
-Barely, right?
-Yeah.
-But the fact that it gets to be
so out in the open and the focus
of it now --
I mean, I think you were
a huge part of the advancements
in the last 30 years
but that must be
such a cool thing to see.
-Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's overwhelming.
You know, it really is.
When I watch the show,
I can't believe
that we're able to have
representation.
You know, when we did
the actual series,
we would meet the original
members of the Peaches,
and they would be like,
you know, 88
and say,
"This is my roommate Betsy."
I'm like, "Oh, hi, Betsy.
Obviously you played shortstop."
She was like, "Yeah, I did."
I'm like, "Okay, and how long
have you guys been roommates?"
"Oh, 52 years."
[ Laughter ]
And it's just --
Society has changed so much.
People don't realize, they say,
"Why didn't Penny add that?"
Well, in 1991 when we were
shooting it, nobody was out.
K.D. Lang wasn't out, right?
I mean, it was a different time.
And I couldn't really believe
where we have gone
in the 30 years.
Although there's
a lot more to go
and I think that representation
is the first step.
And Abbi Jacobson hit it
out of the park, so to speak,
in this "League of Their Own"
thing. She really did.
-Yeah,
she did an incredible job.
And it was really wonderful
to see you in that.
It's wonderful to have you
back here.
Thank you so much, Rosie.
You're always welcome.
-Thank you. Great to see you.
Any time.
You're always welcome.
Rosie O'Donnell, everybody.
New episodes of
"American Gigolo" air
Friday nights on Showtime.
We'll be right back
with Kevin Smith.